this is a production of Cornell
University
but I our four project I'm not going to
talk a lot about this but what we do is
we're a publicly funded program actually
it is USDA funds but some of the money
comes into the university I work at
Rutgers University I'm actually a
Rutgers employee and then the money
comes in and we really develop
regulatory type of data to register
products for specialty crops and minor
uses we're really looking at those those
growers that industry doesn't find
registering products for them profitable
so then we do it for them so so that's a
word from my sponsor we've actually been
been doing this type of work for 50
years we're celebrating our 50 year
anniversary this year but what I really
want to talk about today is really AG
trade and talking with Brad I have a new
new name for what it is now I said free
trade is it really Freight free trade
but it's really a technical barrier to
trade and I'll talk about pesticide
residues and whatnot in in the in the
coming slides but I really want to just
give you an idea of what trade looks
like egg egg trade and where it's been
and really what's the most exciting is
what's really happened in the last five
five this really since well 2008 things
kind of dropped a little bit but it's
just been on a rapid growth since then
and you can see from 2010 it was a
hundred and fifteen billion dollar US
exports going out to other countries and
then it increased to one hundred forty
one thousand one hundred and forty 1
billion in just those two years so you
can really see the rapid amount of
increase that we've had and and I think
in many of the AG industries we can see
what we can see those increases as well
Canada and Mexico has always been the
u.s. major AG trade partner and we've
always run with the surplus in our trade
to Canada but we have Canada here the
red line Mexico again we had a little
drop in 2008 many of the markets but
then it's been a steady increase with
Canada Mexico but the one to really look
at it is really a China and the way that
it's just been a steady increase from
about 7 billion up to over 25 billion
dollars of AG commodities going to
the II use a little bit more of a mature
market so it hasn't really changed too
much and there's been a number of
legislative and other policies that have
been in effect that I think is probably
precluded some of the growth in that
area too
I put India on here just to see you know
we have another country there with over
a billion people in it is that a market
that's still out there that's waiting to
be exercised them and see if we can
increase our exports to India as well
just looking at it by commodities I'm
looking at China
here's soybeans almost 15 billion
dollars of that 25 plus billion going to
China that soy beans going over there
then soybeans in our other Canada Mexico
and the EU you can see there's there's
several billion dollars there as well
when I get to the next commodities you
can see that it's a the value isn't
nearly as high but if we look at fresh
vegetables going to Canada that's our
primary market so the lettuce onions you
know a lot of the fresh vegetables that
we export a lot of those are really
going to Canada then we look at pulses
beans peas dry beans dry peas Mexico's
probably one of our largest markets
there but but then the EU is also
significant amount of market there and
some of these commodities they actually
may be exported to the EU but then they
go to other countries as well from there
tree nuts the EU is our primary exporter
for tree nuts 1.7 billion dollars going
there and then other markets as well a
lot of the products this this is
actually from 2001 to 2003 but this is
this is the percent of crop growing that
is going out to the other markets out
for export so you can see like the
almonds in cotton you know it's almost
70 percent of the commodities being
export of grapes almost 60 percent
soybeans pulses apples probably citrus
pears I put these on here this was 2001
2003 but I think most all of the AG
expansions not been domestic it's hoping
though in export markets so I think
really even though this is from 2001
2003 probably these commodities that
have far exceeded this this twenty to
thirty percent of the market going to
export it's probably closer to fifty
percent now and then again this this is
from 2005 exports for about sixty two
billion I mentioned earlier what we're
over 140 billion now but how does that
impact the the work environment and
contributing to other economic activity
so US agricultural exports that support
additional services so when we're
shipping things international you have
the truck drivers that are taking it to
the ports you have other commodities
potatoes gets chipped french fries so
supporting all the other business
activity more than doubles the economic
impact that you have from these export
commodities so it's a pretty good story
there on what's happening
internationally but what i really want
to talk about is you have past you had a
control past you have to maintain a high
quality product when you're going to be
exporting these commodities and past
really influence that
so the pesticides currently are really a
reality for these these large volumes of
commodities that were producing and
exporting and I've borrowed a lot of
slides throughout my presentations from
the foreign AG service from different
grower groups so this was a comment that
was provided by the California citrus
Quality Council at a meeting that I was
at and they feel that the pesticides I
really they need those technologies to
control plant diseases and insects they
really have to have it to maintain a
high level of phytosanitary demands and
and then growers large and small depend
on pesticides to control plant disease
insects and I had it weeds here to
arrive and I couldn't that go so and
then also the the pesticides and I'm
going to talk about some of the
pesticides that are really more
important to the IPM programs a lot of
the newer ones that actually work into
IPM programs more so than the older
products but I'm going to talk to those
in a few slides but they'll continue to
play a key role in the IPM programs as
well so this technical trade barrier
this thing that may cause problems with
our so-called free trade it's the
maximum pesticide residue levels and
that's really what a legally allowable
amount is is allowed on food and feed
stuff and that that's what results on
the commodity after it's been used
according to a good good agricultural
practice or according to the pesticide
label so sometimes you have some of
these residues from the pesticide that
persist on the commodity
and then for import tolerances the
import tolerances and mrl it's that set
on the basis of the form registered good
agricultural practice and then just some
other considerations again to maintain a
high level of productivity of the
growing world population the food
exports and imports will obviously
continue to rise and now the growers
especially here in the United States
really a growth to support a global
market and as we all know we all like to
have fresh fruits and vegetables when we
go to the supermarket so again this is
from the citrus growers but the growers
really don't don't grow a commodity
they're not really sure where that
commodity is gonna go when they're
growing it in the field so they don't
really manage their production for a
specific market that they're going to
and then even the processors will mix
lots and and mingle things together if
there's no mrl in any of the markets
that they're going to then generally the
pesticide isn't used so and you can see
for citrus some of the major markets
that they're shipping to here the food
quality Protection Act was was passed in
1996 and it really changed the paradigm
of products that we use when we grow our
crops now it's so reduce risk products
that's probably ninety to ninety percent
of the markets that are that are 90
percent of the products that are on the
market are reduce risk products many of
the organophosphate insecticides and
other classes of insecticides have
either been removed from the market or
they've been significantly restricted in
the amount of use that they come in to
eat that can be used and many of these
uses have been replaced by safer
products and one thing to mention is as
a result of the the
food quality Protection Act it actually
required a more comprehensive risk
assessment of each of the products and
in that risk assessment process they
actually determined it wasn't really the
commodities that were the issue but in
most cases it was the applicator so most
of those insecticides were removed from
the market because of the applicator
exposure and they were exceeding the
safe levels for the applicators and also
finally uh many of the new products are
really more IPM compatible oops the more
IPM compatible because they don't impact
the beneficials to the level that the
older products did they can be used in
more specific sites of action this this
was a slide that was given to me from
the Northwest [ __ ] Council and they
just kind of went through what were the
products they use in nineteen ninety
nineteen eighty three to control
coddling moth A's and foster methyl
Bosman
I don't even know what this one is
fossil owned methyl parathion I mean we
all knew methyl parathion was bad in 83
I was still being used in 98 but now now
really the only organophosphates foz met
and many of these other ones are
considered reduced risk products
especially the chlorine Tran 'april and
the methoxy femicide but these work on
very specific sites of action on the
insects you could continue to use a lot
of them you're going to get resistance
so the toolbox has to be bigger so you
can rotate your chemistry's and prevent
resistance as well
yeah I have another slide coming up and
I'll talk about that a little more but
really when you talk about risk you're
talking about the hazard and the
exposure so when you talk about reduce
risk products you mostly focus on the
hazard part of the equation the exposure
may be equal to or greater on the
reduced risk products you know the
exposure may be equal to or greater on
these because you don't many of these
you don't need a applicator protection
equipment when you're making the
applications because they are the level
of hazard is so low that they don't they
don't have to be concerned about it
obviously if they're applying FA's net
they're gonna have you know the overalls
on they're going to have a mask on
but with a lot of these other compounds
really probably all you need is like
rubber gloves and maybe so a splash
apron or something like that
so but we're really with the reduced
risk we're really talking about the
hazard part of the risk equation and I'm
sorry I have a little bit of a cold
right now some sound a little rougher
than I normally do so IPM again I think
we talked about a lot of that but how
these new products really fit into IPM
programs and one actually that was
submitted to the agency really just
about a year ago is actually even safe
to the pollinators so it's safe to bees
and other pollinators as well so you can
see this transition from the Opie's
reduce risk and these products that are
moving into it but the problem that
we're having is we've registered these
products for the growers in the US but
some of the other countries don't
recognize those products they've never
seen them they've never seen the tox
packages that were used to support them
so when we're exporting our commodities
abroad then they say well I don't know
if the residues from this compound are
safe or not so that's really what I'm
going to focus my talk on today and the
growers don't always know where their
commodities are going a globalization
could preclude the use of a new pest
control product a new a new pest control
product that may be very valuable to an
IPM
Oh Graham as well and the use of any
pesticide and actually what I've seen is
even some of these newer products were
actually seeing probably a little bit
higher residues from the pesticide they
got very short treatment the harvest
interval and some of them actually stay
stay active in the plant for a longer
period of time too so we're actually
seeing probably a little more residues
present in the plant than we did it like
with the pyrethroids or the
organophosphates because a lot of those
are just kind of you go on you make your
application and then the compound would
break down fairly quickly but the newer
products don't break down quite as
quickly but they're a lot safer
all right so major market export flow
you know we I talked about the trade
within the US Mexico Canada we have a
lot of trade going going back and forth
there but then we have trade to Europe
we have trade to Asia Australia New
Zealand South America trades with us
they bring the trade up to us but then
we even find that we have trade going we
may be shipping something out from one
place and then something else comes back
so it's very complicated now that the
trade paths and there's a lot of people
that are studying you know the the
citrus people for example what are our
major trade our markets that we're going
to the companies that develop some of
these products okay if I develop it
develop it for use on lettuce where do I
need to make sure that I have trade MRLs
established for those markets that our
growers are going to use and then just
some other considerations is it's not
necessarily even that you're going to
consume it but I mean from my discussion
with the cranberry growers they grow the
cranberries in Maine Massachusetts New
Jersey sometimes they'll just ship them
right across the border just to get them
juiced and then they want to bring them
back into the country but if there's a
pesticide residue on them they can't do
that because the Canada didn't recognize
that mrl that was was being used on it
in some cases in other cases it it may
be uh it may be okay to attack export it
to Canada and then grapes that we've
seen a similar thing even grapes coming
from Ontario into New York we've had
some issues with some pesticide residues
appearing on the commodities so the the
maximum residue limits the pesticide
residues can really preclude some of
these shipments and and really more
efficient and and more use of the
resources that are available to the
growers like the juicing plants and
whatnot so my friend from the Northwest
[ __ ] Council he said why do you always
use apples and you know that's like the
commodity that we've decided to use but
you know in the u.s. we may have a use
pattern and it results
in in a five part per million residue
level on the apples and then you have in
Canada well maybe they don't need so
much so they have a lower mrl on the
apples in Canada and then you have you
go around the world there's different
use patterns you know maybe summer use
pre bloom post bloom so depending on
where you are in the world you may have
a different pesticide residue limit on
that commodity so you can imagine when
you're trying to trade your apples in
the US that were treated and and they
could result in a and five parts per
million and you're trying to export to
other parts of the kind of issues that
you can run into so in the ideal world
then everybody would have the same RL so
that's kind of where we want to get with
the harmonization so I'm going to kind
of switch gears a little bit just talk
about registration and how pesticides
are regulated for a few minutes and then
I'm going to come back to some of some
of the other trade issues but in the
u.s. really EPA is the only body that
really regulates pesticides it's it's
regulated under the federal insecticide
fungicide rodenticide Act and there's
just been a number of amendments that
have been made from from year-to-year
the food quality Protection Act actually
made amendments to the the FIFRA Act and
then in the in the North American
countries we have PMR a pest management
regulatory anat agency that regulates
pesticides in Canada and then Mexico
it's a little similar to what we used to
do here in some of the other countries
do it as well they have they have like a
Health Department and they have an Ag
Department and then they work together
to regulate the pesticides and then
globally we have the EU the European
Commission Korea China and I think
probably what we'd like to see is that
all of these countries work under the
Codex standards Codex is an author
marius kind of a global standard that's
recognized in some countries but not all
countries as a standard for pests
residue limits and then the organization
of Economic Cooperation and Development
they don't really set standards but they
provide a guidance documents to the
member countries that work with them so
in in the US when you're going to submit
a pesticide you have to generate data in
all these different areas this is a
conventional product I'm going to talk
about bio pesticides and microbials in a
few minutes but yet that you have to
generate data in all these different
areas before you can get your product
registered in the US so you have your
your product properties fate transport
environmental fate spray drift
ecological effects chemistry health
effects test testing guidelines these
are all your cancer studies that you're
doing with various tests test animals
that's actually going through changes
now we're at where they're gonna they
call it century 21 talks and they're
going to be doing more in vitro testing
instead of animal testing occupational
resident to exposure these all these
studies actually could cost probably up
to from when a company decides to
develop a product and they're going to
take it to the registration it's about
two hundred fifty million dollars worth
of studies that they invest and then
some of the the more recent studies that
they were required but most people use
waivers in the past but now they
actually have to generate data but
developmental neural talks and immuno
talks
and then for some of our other areas
like the microbial pesticides bio
chemicals for the the conventional
products there's three divisions in EPA
that that review the data that comes in
form for these products are they're
independent
divisions that that cover themselves for
the bio chemicals no in most cases
you're going to get an exemption from an
mrl exemption from a tolerance but the
division still has to review what we
call a 6-pack of talks data just to make
sure that there's no toxology code
with those biologicals and then
microbials that's more of your your
counter cleaners and items like that and
and again they don't have to go through
the extent of environmental fate and
type of studies there but they do have
to do up more performance testing for
the mic microbial pesticides so I talked
about this already we got a risk
equation in this this is the global
definition of risk
it's hazard times exposure equals your
risk the hazards identified through all
those toxicity studies that I mentioned
and then exposure you have some studies
that you conduct but a lot of it's also
modeling and when your model obviously
you can you can do various aspects of
the modeling and I'm going to talk about
some of the refinements that you can do
with some of this modeling but and then
as I mentioned earlier to the reduce
risk products are really lower hazard
products and some of the products that
are actually being registered now they
can't seem to find any tox endpoints not
all of them but but there's some of them
that they really so and then fqp a
really all these items were looked at
separately before fqp a but now it's all
put in to the same risk up under that
active ingredient so if you're using
something on your pet and you're
consuming peas and it's treated with the
same thing that's all part of the risk
assessment if you're using it around
your house for termite control but then
you got a grower that's using it it's
still considered in the risk of all
these items used to be looked at
separately but now they're looked at
together on their F qpa so the maximum
residue limits the use for enforcement
to make sure that there's proper
application that's what it's at the
local level they're looking at okay if
you're exceeding your tolerance you're
not probably you're probably not using
the product according to the label that
was out there so they'll use it for
enforcement then it's also used for
standards for commodities and trade and
that's also domestically as well as
internationally so if somebody's
shipping something across state lines
California I think
they probably have a monitoring program
to make sure that the the pesticide
residue limits are underneath those
standards that were set the MEK the
maximum residue limit is only set if the
dietary exposure risk assessment
confirms that there's no no human health
concerns to any segment of the
population obviously kids are the
biggest segment probably that were the
most concern about maybe women of the
childbearing age is the next segment of
the population now that we're concerned
about so the EPA as well as any
regulatory agency they will not set an
mrl unless there's no human health
concerns to any segment of the
population and then we also have every
country has or is developing their own
regulatory system some of them are
independent like the EPA is independent
and then some of them actually default
the Codex as a standard but one of the
problems is with commodities and trade
is that not all countries recognize
codex at the global standard so talking
about risk again we have our risk
endpoint and what I want to mention here
is that the noah noel level is a no
observable effect level so when you do
your your your tox testing so you have
different levels that you're testing so
most of the reduced risk products and
the newer products are really a no
observable effect level some of the
older products there is a lowest level
of observable effect and depending on
where you ran your studies you could
either have you know if you're below
that level you probably would never seen
anything in the studies in the first
place and then and then from that level
you're no observable effect level then
they automatically add a 10x interest
species and another 10x interspecies
safety factor and with FQ PA they also
added another 10x for kids so you have
your 10x you know from humans and dogs
and then another 10x from within humans
so Robin and I we may have different
our genetic profiles so they want to add
another 10x safety factor and then four
kids add an art that's the risk endpoint
here that they're started from and then
when they register a new product most of
the time they don't have any refinements
so they're kind of way out here but but
if if the risk up seems to be filling up
with no refinements then they may look
at refinements such as percent of crop
treated obviously not all the crop may
be treated with the pesticide they look
at the diet and then the Tier three
they'll even take the market data that
that's being generated by the USDA and
see what the values are that they're
finding there when we do these residue
studies we're looking for what we call
the worst case scenario so if there's
three applications that that we think
the grower may need we'll put the three
applications on there if it's cucumbers
it's an insecticide it's probably be a
one-day pH I so then we harvest that
sample as it's at the farm gate with the
one-day pH I then it goes out to the
market and but but for us when we do the
regulatory work we're looking at really
what the farm gate value is so the
registration process you know
Discovery's probably two to five years
regulatory research three to five years
and then EPA review two years so what's
being developed now is probably really
not going to be available to growers for
another ten years and that that's one of
the issues we get when we have our
workshops Robin because we have we had
our workshop a week ago to set what our
priorities are and we're not doing a
discovery or even some of the long-term
regulatory data we're just doing a
residue study and then we're submitting
it to EPA but our timelines about five
years to registration and then you stack
on top of that you have the EPA review
of the Canadian review EU review codex
review you can just see that you know by
the time a commodity can actually use
the product and tray can be quite long
some of these there's a global joint
review process and some of these are
done concurrently but then codex it
always does it after
reviews been approved so some of the
international cooperation in these areas
oops you can see all the different
regulatory agencies that are working on
on harmonizing the mrl that are in trade
so now just a comment about the global
joint review process it's where several
national authorities work together to
review an active ingredient at the same
time so they receive the same submission
they develop a joint schedule they
divide up the work and then at the
conclusion they make their own
regulatory decision which is independent
but what the hope is is that they end up
with similar endpoints and the MRLs are
similar to so them meant ratings not
impacted so just there's a lot of
information on here but I really just
want to focus on this chlorine Tran
'april product that was registered and
these are all the partners that
participated in the global joint review
process so you can see the US reviewed
the talks up toxicology studies
Australia reviewed the residue chemistry
the United Kingdom the Eco talk studies
Ireland the environmental fate and then
Canada reviewed the product chemistry so
you can see where you know it's less
redundant and you're using your
resources more wisely that way so in the
end the the compound was submitted in
2007 registered for joint review in
their countries have participated in
2008 and now it's registered in over 100
countries and the commodities that are
treated with that product don't really
need to be concerned when they're in
trade channels if they're going to be
detected as an issue and it's it's
really becoming a way of doing business
but the one thing I can mention is in
the EU for example they had a
legislative change of two years ago and
it made it very difficult for them to
participate in this process so now they
they were kind of working along
everything was going fine they have a
legislative change then they got a
retool
and then decide how they can participate
in this this global process what but
what the hope is is with these joint
reviews is that we can have a
harmonization of the tools harmonization
of the the data evaluation records that
are used in reviewing of products then
those submissions are all the same that
if you're in the u.s. if you're in the
EU your review is going to look the same
as any other country in the world so
then hopefully the process will be
something that builds on itself more
more countries will participate in it
more international organizations and and
the other thing we hope is that the
minor uses or special uses will be
dovetailed into those reviews as well so
the grower concerns diminishing reliance
on codex MRLs or reach or just the
refusal to use codex as an international
standard that's a that's a problem for
the growers there's a growing backlog of
reviews at codex so we already have the
new products registered in the US but
we're still waiting for codex to review
it so then we can export to those
countries that that respect the Codex
standard and then there's a
proliferation of country-specific MRLs
and that's what we call a positive list
so japan has a positive positive list
Korea used to respect codex now they
want their own positive list India used
to respect codex now they want their own
positive list if the product you use on
your commodity is on that positive list
you're okay but if the product you're
using is not on that list
then you're not going to be exporting to
that country and then the other thing
I'm going to talk about a little later
is just the secondary standards with the
food retailer MRLs and they're even
lower than the national standards or
pesticide use restrictions so
so the main main challenges is a
continued loss of key key protection
products and this was actually something
I got from a grower in the UK they grow
salads green crops but what he indicated
is their loss of key protection products
what we saw here with the loss of the
organophosphates and then there's a more
limited mechanism of action for the
products that they are using so there's
more pressure on resistance management
and then once you have resistance and
obviously you're losing your efficacy
and then we're already seeing resistance
to the pyrethroids and other other
compounds so what they really need is
effective control with minimum residues
to meet the demands of their customers
another grower reality growers need a
wide variety of pesticide tools to
control their pests but also to manage
resistance and and integrate with the
IPM programs and also the with the
greater demand on trade so in conclusion
it's really there's a scarcity of MRLs
that prevents trades and delays
transition to the newer safer products
and listen this one's up this one also
focuses on on the secondary standard so
you have food retailers that set
arbitrary pesticide residue levels or
limit specific pesticides that can be
used to convince their consumers that
their food is safe but then the growers
are forced to manage residues there's no
late season uses because they're
managing pesticide residue limits
they're trying to mitigate the resset
residue levels and then then they have
lost the quality because poor insect
control and less residue leads to
resistance as well and fewer pesticide
cause resistance and disrupts the IPM
program I think one thing I'd like to
add there too is uh
you know we developed these IPM programs
and then we have something like that the
brown marmorated stink bug that comes in
and the growers are basically throwing
anything they can at the the stink bug
and it completely destroys their IPM
programs it's almost almost like they
have to start over but these trade
standards also affect their organic
production as well we registered thymol
for use in beehives that control
tracheal mite and bee hives in the US
it's an exemption from the requirement
of Tolerance but in the EU it has it has
an actual mrl value so so we have an
issue because we don't regulate the the
residue level in the US but the EU does
spinosa it has MRLs in the US it's
probably going to be regulated as a
conventional product internationally so
it'll be it will require MRLs but most
of the bile pesticides really they don't
have MRLs or they're what's called an
exemption from the requirement of
tolerance in the US but there's a lot of
variability for biopesticides across the
world on how they regulate them some of
them actually require certain levels
some of them like the u.s. they're
exempt from tolerance but but they do a
safety finding on a secondary standards
is it's a way in which retailers try to
respond to their consumer needs and
their expectations but they're not
really established following any
principles or guidelines that's actually
used as a rule of trade between
countries so it really kind of I say
ignore here but it really complicates
all of these other trade efforts that
are going on because we you have
regulatory bodies working together
trying to harmonize trade and then you
throw another standard on top of that
and the growers just don't know what to
do I mean they can use a product that
they think it's going to be fine going
to the EU but then when it gets there if
the retailer's reject it it's a
commodity that's going to be lost so
it's not necessarily risk-based or
science based it really doesn't really
take into account special needs of
developing countries either and I say
that because a lot of these secondary
standard slides that I use was from a
colleague of mine that gave a
presentation on this but it's really a
market strategy and they're really
arbitrarily setting the standards when I
talked about setting the MRLs earlier I
talked that the MRLs are set on what the
use pattern is that the grower has and
then it's determined to be safe so if
the levels were higher or lower it would
still meet the safety finding so if if
if a secondary standard set and they say
well you know that mrl is 5 we're just
going to we want ours to be 2.5 well
it's not really set on science it sort
of just said on what they think their
consumers want to hear
and then finally it can crowd out
smallholders it can be adding
unnecessary cost and also effects
efficacy of the product and yield and
and for the growers it really doesn't
mean a better price either
so let me just close with a few closing
thoughts global trade of Ag products
it's increased tremendously over the
past five years and that's in spite of
the economic factors and and maybe
that's kind of a look into the future
where the global population is going it
continues to increase but this is really
the bright bright spot of our economy is
really agriculture it's really kind of
an exciting place to be right now but
there's a lot of regulation of
pesticides not only at the local level
but the national and also international
levels and all that is really to ensure
consumer safety from the get-go
pesticide residues do have a major
impact on trade and it really requires a
significant effort by the brokers
traders and the growers to manage to
make sure that that the trade continues
to expand and that that's one thing we
really want to see that that trade
continue to expand in the way that it
has been in the last five years and
growers are certainly impacted by the
the pesticide residue limits and how it
affects their pest control decisions
well what will some of the regulatory
cooperation agreements with Canada we
have a regulatory cooperation Council
that was signed by Prime Minister Harper
and President Obama they want to remove
some of the regulatory hurdles that
impact trade well will that increase our
trade and harmonization
EU is also considered another type of
regulatory trade agreement the Pacific
Rim countries there's also discussions
there about harmonizing some of the
regulatory barriers that that impact
trade continued movement the
harmonizations required to support
expansions and should be
sitter as more countries are developing
new systems so instead of each company
reinventing the wheel we should all be
working together to make sure we're
really inventing the same wheel or using
the same wheel and then I have to ask
what will the next paradigm shift be in
pesticides we see what the flu quality
Protection Act did to the products that
are being used now but can we get to a
point where where the MRLs may be no
longer required I talked about the bio
pesticides most of those are exempt from
Tolerance some of the conventional
products that EPA's reviewed they're
actually establishing exemption from
tolerance on the products that they're
registering internationally it's not
respected so we still have to generate
residue data if we're going to be
exporting commodities abroad so what I
hope is that we can get to a point where
we have some harmonization and the new
products that are developed really won't
require these these trade barriers to
impact them so with that I thank you for
your attention and I'll take any
questions or comments
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu